pretty exciting stuff it probably would
have been the biggest event in las vegas
in years
um but it was held at an allegiant
stadium and there weren't any fans
raiders and the chiefs though came out
slugging like a couple of heavyweights
in a title fight chris you've got the
details of
yesterday's big matchup yeah really it
was a lot of fun and yeah well even
without fans it was a great night here
like heavyweight title fight
you had some interesting games hey if
not for this cobid lockdown
las vegas would have had a party like it
hadn't seen before the world champion
chiefs
coming into las vegas on a sunday night
in prime time
boy it was big and both teams throwing
those big punches with the raiders
landing some blows that had the champs
wobbling on the canvas but they just
couldn't deliver the knockout
raiders scored with under two minutes to
play here but that gave mahomes the
magician
just too much time boy he led the chiefs
down the field
for the game-winning score oh you could
point your finger at a number of
mistakes not offensively but on defense
car and company did their job it was a
defense that couldn't make enough big
plays
but like gruden says he's got a few
bullet points that need to get this
thing fixed
we didn't play well enough on defense
and we can uh
make a lot of excuses and legitimate
excuses for that we're missing
some key players we have a young
secondary
we had guys that didn't practice we
played the world champions coming off of
bye week we can make all kind of excuses
but
we we i say we me included we gave up 36
first downs and we didn't get it done we
got to play a lot better
all right now the raiders are 6-4 on the
season same record as last year after 10
games but
this is a far better 6-4 team and now
they've got to go out and prove it on
the road they meet the atlanta falcons
sunday
it is 10 a.m start vegas time and it's
going to be an interesting game dave
let's see what happens looking forward
to that chris thanks so much come